so I guess obvious first question we
want to ask you is well obvious first
thing is congratulations
congratulations but uh first question is
what's it like being a dad now that
you're a dad now no sleep S I don't even
remember what it felt like to be
properly rested yeah really four hours
every day no no no no no no six maybe oh
okay okay yeah do that for five months
yeah okay yeah I
knew so so bad yeah once maybe it's not
just your early it's not just your early
YouTube
he was you was younger he was younger
back then not just every you now I can't
do it anymore oh oh God no it's great
yeah it's really fun I how was it I
guess having a child in a foreign
country especially like Japan I think a
lot of people cous to know like was it
was it was it easy was it was there a
lot of funny little things you didn't
expect or probably more question for
marsia to be honest yeah true you you
like chilling you like yeah you're just
chilling man yeah I mean yeah it's it's
different for sure I'm amazed she was
able to do that like in a foreign
country the [__] were we thinking but
yeah yeah I mean especially cuz your kid
probably has the worst name for Japanese
people to pronounce sounds that bad it
how do they say it how do they say it
how would the Japanese people
sayun ohun okay cuz I was thinking it
was just going to
beong maybe six but they have the it's
really he the baby brand baby be oh yeah
so you just reference there you go it
happen just
now yeah they know it so they're like oh
you're like oh same the same so that
works uh so you got to figure it out
that's it it's easy just just name your
kid after a brand sorry I just remember
I asked you I was like is Vero like is
that a bad name you were like no it's
great and now I come here you the word
wa like is it bad in Japanese doesn't
mean anything else
you asked you asked me is it you asked
me is it a does it mean anything bad in
Japanese and I said no no you said
that's a beautiful name yeah and I think
it's a beautiful name it doesn't change
the fact that I think it's hard for
Japanese people to pronounce talking mad
[__] behind yeah he he was saying the
wildest [__] I'm like who the
[__] should we get our cofes yes it
means bear in oh it's so funny actually
milk for him and soy honey for me yeah
sorry I'm the oak guy your is coming
your is coming oh yeah you want mine you
have M you the guest I didn't get
Guatemala you did get guala guala ni
sorry what you saying oh no I had to
reorder theirs so that's for everyone
else that's for Kai Kai you and Alex
okay I'm sorry I forgot what I was
goingon to say means bear it means bear
okay yeah yeah because we always go to
the vaccination and whatever checkup and
it's always just me mar and a bunch of
moms yeah Japanese dads don't exist I
seen one uh well they don't go in the uh
you were saying that it's not common for
Japanese dads to be in the uh the room
when yes the bum's giving birth yeah
which is it's a very Japanese mentality
if you're like ah I'll see him when he's
when he's clean and stuff it's also the
worst cuz they were also you know it's
against the uh rules to no no no the
pain killer thing like no you should
have a natural birth as
Welles only reason the Japanese women
are like no yeah yeah yeah you have to
like you have to either go to a specific
hospital or you have to like really push
for Comm like were you in the room uh
yeah they brought me in for the finale
yeah for the finale so so you were just
like chilling playing I wasn't there for
the entire season but I was there for
the final
episode they gave me a rund down you
know and then like posted on Twitter
guys it was a hard for 12 hours but it
was worth it they they gave me the
they gave you the cliff notes what were
you doing then during the they kept me
at home yeah you you at home you just
chilling you're like alled to be outside
yeah wow they were like mind say was the
one that had to text me too it wasn't
even like the nurses talking to me or
something oh my God so she's texting
give the updates yeah yeah yeah and
she's like okay come now and then I yeah
I didn't hear anything for a while and I
was like I wonder if I have time to pee
and then of course as soon as I go to
the bathroom she's like come now and I'm
like uh but they brought me in for the
highlight and everything went great so
yeah happy yeah I Japan's service is
really good with child bear so that's a
good part of all I me they they got to
make it good it's a rare event they got
to get yeah it's becoming once a year
thing they got to make it as appealing
as it could possibly be yeah I think
they have the lowest child death in in
among the world so I think yeah careers
I think fertility is different from bir
three I is it I can't remember if it is
those my whole bunch of statistics about
it yeah okay point being no one wants to
have babies yeah well it's cuz you can't
cuz when is it your turn yeah when is it
I'm doing what you guys did to me now
your
reference how do he know how does he
know okay off the what are we ask watch
them watch them [__] when when is it
yeah Joey yeah Joey when's what do you
mean you're the married man you're
you're the closest gone as closest yeah
I mean I mean it's something I mean I
talked about it no pressure by I was
just joking oh no get enough pressure
for my family
anyway this going to find out anything
compared to going to a family family
reunion getting the 20 different aunts
asking me that's like that's like hard
mode this is just like chill but uh yeah
I mean I guess it will come when it will
come this is not any hint stop looking
at my eyes and just
like likey studying my body language to
Gemini he's lying right now actually
this
is but uh I think I want a kid's
sometime the next few years that's what
I think I don't I don't kind of know
maybe it'll happen earlier maybe it'll
happen later who knows when you're ready
you're ready yeah exactly well were you
ready you think yeah well yes and no I
guess yeah you get you get nine months
to prepare yeah you're not
prepared we were yeah we were trying to
like U find all the pay to pay to win
our way through like getting all the
every Amazon baby machine there is we're
going to solve baby racing the pay win
for conception I was just like what do
that you can do that I guess yeah uh
yeah it's hard
so's what's the most hardest thing
you've had to learn as sleep sleep for
sure sleep it really kills you after a
while yeah I guess you just have to
sleep when the baby sleeps that's the
common thing that people say yeah what a
great idea Connor just I wouldn't know
the baby doesn't sleep what do you mean
he's got to sleep he's got to sleep at
some point he's when he's got to up
every hour go crazy [__] now we're going
to sleep turning soon and I can't wait
it's going to be great you should just
send them off to
boarding this guy suggestions too oh my
God no it's great you should get the
Asian mentality which it just pass it
off to your like their grand
yeah be like that would have been very
helpful like Mom Dad you take care of
the baby for a weekend let us well they
they a lot of uh a lot of like um
interesting uh articles have been raised
about how like a lot of people nowadays
don't have their grandparents raising
kids and it's like one of the reasons
why a lot of people don't want to have
kids it's like they don't have any other
external supports when you were when you
were growing up right you had aunts you
had your uh you know grandparents
helping you and whoever else and and now
it's kind of mostly on the parents
grandparents I mean it's especially
tough like you know in your instance
because all of your family extended
family doesn't live in Japan
grandparents would have been helpful for
sure I think my I think my older brother
cu i' I've got a nephew I think he moved
back to go near my like parents house he
like just that makes and they're pros at
that point they're like no concerns I
feel like when you if I had a kid I'd be
very worried about everything yeah where
I think grandparents are like nah [__]
it we'll figure it out do this you were
fine be fine yeah it be fine yeah well
am I
fine they raed a weird kid I think Mar
is the worrying oh really you're like
was F
whatever were there any like weird
skills you have to learn in preparation
like
[__] to learn cuz I I want to know what
I've got like what I've got to like I
guess look forward to I'll help you
out what's the what's the because I
think when I want to have a kid right I
want to like I want to like make him
like cool so I I would start from day
one I'm like all right start showing
them cool stuff right away
subconsciously making them think that
like video games are cool okay I think
they will like that anyway they will
like that anyway but like the right
video games I'll give like two piles of
like Foods one will have Subway Surface
one will have alen ring and he crawls
towards and if he goes towards the
subway stuff he gets no food that's the
so he just has to learn he goes to
boarding
school and then he and then he resents
me but at least he'll be
decision the right this is a joke by the
way that's an interesting approach yeah
consider it you should you should really
take this from a GU no children you
should really consider that no no I'll
do that
yeah what age do you think you going to
let your uh let your kids start gaming
soon as possible soon as possible
absolutely gamer baby he's gonna be
playing like the worst games you're
going to be disappointed no no no no any
game I'll
play it's like he's five months so they
can't really do much yeah yeah my my
family's like what can you do now I'm
like yeah still a baby like what what
age do they start doing stuff like d dud
like poke it with a stick like come on
come on I mean you can play with him for
sure but like yeah it's I mean radle
noises it's not like I they don't start
walking for like another five months at
least right that up I didn't realize how
long it I we speed that up a little bit
speedrun
Str speedrun razor
CH the
walk yeah first words what like what was
it like first words how long does that
take normally can can be I should know
that uh no uh I think it's like a year
maybe a year okay I think you learn a
walk before you learn your first work
right or is it the other way around I I
should know that yeah I don't know I
don't know how long does it take yeah
speaking their first words in 11 to 13
months 11 to 13 [__] they're slow aren
they he's already accidentally they they
say mama all the time he doesn't know
what it means yeah this is a sound they
make and I'm like Mom's rigged
it have no chance to be the first right
yeah you're done you're done yeah but
you can be the cool dad no yeah for sure
you're going to be the cool dad right
well the fun dad I guess yeah okay well
I saw you've written off cool dad you're
like we'll see I saw you trying to learn
as many cool things as possible like
this and a short a time period to uh
impress your son what do you think is
like what what's the funnest thing that
you've learned that you think will be
the most impressive [__] know yeah I
don't know babies are amazed by anything
like you can show him anything and he's
like wow so I don't know be a big
confidence booster yeah yeah it's great
just seeing the big yeah yeah he laughs
at anything it's hilarious like I am
pretty funny I know speaking speaking of
that I do love the way BJ laughs it's
very cute he just sounds like an old man
he sounds like an old man yeah he's
like he doesn't know how to laugh it's
really cute yeah uh I saw you uh when
you you learning your skills you did
this uh the art video where
you off your art journey and I I yeah I
am yeah I Sor I don't know you put it in
SE I don't think you're on Twitter but
it's kind of sent Twitter into a really
interesting uh ation a lot of people
like what the [__] he actually got good
okay nice a lot of people were very like
imp it was not like any negative or
anything but it was very people were a
lot talking about it a lot like I
definitely don't want to piss off the
art community that's no it's generally
that there were some people who are like
I'm a lot of people are like that's
[__] up that I took me five years to
get to where he got uh like stuff like
that but I you know it was a really it
was really interesting video you cuz
they ain't you yeah and I guess you
didn't even realize people you'd caus a
bit of a conversation on Twitter yeah a
lot of people were talking about it what
would you wanted to get into there I
don't know just a wh so where's so
what's your devard account I don't have
it I you know I watched I watched that
video and I was watching I was like man
I I I'm impressed that you don't get
frustrated with this and want to stop I
got really frustrated how how do you
keep going I don't it's for a son no
know real real reason only I just want
to draw cute anime girls come on B all
right well that's I that's a good enough
reason I do get that question a lot and
I I generally I don't know you don't
know you have no idea what why a
different man all right all right about
the grind s okay all right all I wake up
at 5:00 a.m. cuz the kid wakes you up
yes as soon as I saw you doing that
video and saw you like I'm going to
choose to draw girls I was like yeah my
man my man
knows St you didn't want to go for
muscular man or maybe that's the next
step yeah muscles are hard I think
that's exactly right yeah that's fine
I'm still doing it I find it amusing
that you found Ane girls to draw easier
than like any other art style do you
think anime is just an easier art style
to beginners cuz it's kind of stripped
down of it's not realistic looking right
think so there's like there's like a
weird formula to it as well right that's
like a little bit harder to kind of
deviate from even if you wanted to cuz
like if you deviate a little bit from
the anime art style it just doesn't yeah
yeah yeah you try and give them lips and
it's like what the [__] is this it looks
curs as hell you make their draw their
nose like yeah what the [__] is this
yeah like an anime character with dsls
just looks a little bit little weird it
doesn't work I think it's cuz the eyes
are so big anything else just yeah takes
up a lot of room yeah but it gives me
hope because I think I have like
negative art skills and seeing how you
should try it yeah see how fast yeah I
do I do I see how fast you improved in
such a short period of time or maybe
you're just Talent like naturally
talented talented at it I don't know I
don't know